I swear there's so much stuff going on
this week but okay fairly big news
coming out of DC in terms of the future
of DC movies and TV related material
they have found a replacement for the
outgoing Walter Hamada who was the head
of that particular area of Warner
Brothers Discovery he is being replaced
by producer Peter Safran and director
James Gunn they're going to serve as
co-ceos and chairman of that with
saffron handling the business kind of
thing and guns serving as the head of
the creative things he's expected to
still direct some things himself but he
will be overseeing the general creative
direction of the DC films and
televisions going forward and broadly
speaking yeah actually this seems like a
really good plan seems like something
they probably should have done a while
ago I'm not gonna completely celebrate
quite yet because
uh David's ass love is still in charge
of Warner Brothers Discovery and there's
so much nonsense going on as they
restructure that I don't know how much
to trust this but in and of itself it's
good news